want to know what's heating up theaters  this weekend used to hold that girl in  the palm of my hand he was becoming a  woman you're gonna have to deal with  that Thanks who's looking for that  parents try to keep their daughters from  having sex in blockers in a  post-apocalyptic world a family lives in  total silence fearful of an unknown  threat in a quiet place dead body holds  a lot of Secrets those can be the  difference between guilt and innocence  in Chappaquiddick  Ted Kennedy deals with the personal and  political consequences of a tragic auto  accident see what's hot in theaters with  this week's fantasy patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]